(happy music)
- Look at all the colors, it's so pretty.
- Whoa.
- [Both] Slide, slide slippery slide.
(laughing)
- Oh my god!
- And then just kick over like that.
- Let me try!
- One more time.
- Slide, wait.
- [Both] Slide, slide, slippery slide.
(happy music)
(laughing)
- Back, front, one, two.
(laughter)
- Oh my god!
- Okay, okay.
- One more time!
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- There's a secret.
- What's the secret?
- It's magical.
(peppy music)
(plate clanks)
- Hey!
- What?
- Give me it back!
- Uhh, so hot.
- Not as hot as me.
- Hurry up.
(knocking)
- Is that my shirt?
- No, maybe.
- Give me back!
(laughing)
- Oh, oh.
- Oh my gosh, I am moisturizing.
- Do, do, do, do, do, bah!
(peppy music)
(laughing)
- Good to see you!
- You look beautiful!
- I miss you so much.
- I miss you.
Mama's gonna be so excited to see you.
- Aw, how's she doin'?
- She's okay, she's--
- She's good?
- You know, she's been better.
- Oh my god.
- Do you remember?
- Yes, how did you find that?
- It was buried deep,
deep in dad's old boxes.
- I thought we lost that forever ago.
- No, we did not.
- All right, let's get food.
- Yes, starving.
- Dying.
(laughing)
- Okay.
(peppy music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)